merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
prise de parole de salé lavrov
nous sommes en jeu que j'avais la boj va
parfaitement augmenter le problème
central des relations internationales
aujourd'hui et surtout de la passe du
moment qui voudraient se construit avec
s'est développée entre les nations c'est
le problème de cette guerre de cet
russophobie qui se développe et qui sont
en fait investi tous les canaux
possibles de la diplomatie comme il l'a
noté a dit que je vérifie fait des
propositions au niveau de ses
propositions sans cigare t il le succès
en fait que la russie propose quelque
chose que a priori le monde attentisme
refuse ainsi on voit réellement ça te
manger aux politiques qui à
ceux des fines qui
s'intensifie c'est le monde atlantiste
sergueï lavrov a déclaré je le cite nos
collègues ont perdu la notion de
dialogue c'est votre constat c'est ce
que vous disiez à l'instant il a dressé
aussi avant de terminer son intervention
le tableau de l'otan actuel quel constat
fait tilt
en fait ils soulignent et à plusieurs
reprises d'ailleurs c'est ambigu le
rapport entre le droit et la politique
puisque
engagement je vais diction prix ce qui
ne veut pas dire que si le contexte
politique change ses engagements
juridiques ne vont pas devenir caduque
hanche et donc dans ce cas là la
politique prime sur le droit surtout le
droit international et il faut bien
comprendre que tout nouveau droit
international et le résultat en quelque
sorte d'un combat politique et c'est la
vision du vainqueur qui fixez un certain
moment dans un marbre à très fragile
finalement qu'est le marbre juridique
hanche dont il ne faut pas non plus
surestimer la situation ce qui compte ce
sont très concrètement
pour vous et depuis longtemps affirmé
par l'otan d'intégrer du cren et la
géorgie on peut se demander dans quelle
mesure c'est un discours dans quelle
mesure c'est une réalité parce que
par exemple à l'égard de l'ukraine a
quand même précisé que de toute façon ne
craigne chef a le soutien des pays de
l'otan mais elles ne bénéficient en
aucun cas de la protection militaire
commune de l'otan donc
la part de l'otan je suis surtout ce
discours à l'égard de l'ukraine et de la
géorgie pour faire pression sur l'armée
cominar mans en fait vous voilà pays mis
quasiment qui s'est adressé directement
françois lamy le chef de la diplomatie
russe a accusé l'otan et ses alliés de
refuser d'étudier les propositions
visant une désescalade détention il a
mises en garde aussi contre le retour je
le cite du scénario cauchemar de la
confrontation militaire c'est bien le
risque qui pointe aujourd'hui
il a toujours un risque de confrontation
lorsqu'il y à une impasse qui est en
commandite qui coûte cher très cher a eu
de partir il peut y avoir cette nation
fausse selon laquelle la guerre sale en
plein conflit qu'on imagine toujours
organisés au départ que l'on imagine
qu'ils ont ou au départ serait le moyen
de sortir d'une impasse c'est à
une chose impression que de toute
manière
les guerres dont je n'ai rien réglé et
les conflits ont dû être gérer
politiquement de toute manière derrière
sens pour moi ils ont permis de faire
gagner un plan ou auch en l'occurrence
je ne pense pas que pour l'instant
réellement les pays de l'otan je passe à
la d'abord parce que le potentiel
militaire de la russie est loin d'être
négligeable et que comme elle l'a
démontré en rit elle sait parfaitement
conservés a donc chassé un point qui
fait peur et qui fait reculer deuxième
aspect parce que comme l'a déclaré
magirus à lille i à des barrières qui
mettrait en péril la sécurité de l'est
par la suite litoria cela est une
position qui a également été confirmée
par le directeur du renseignement russes
sans forcément extérieur russe h et dans
ce cas là la russie mettra tout ce qui
est dans son pouvoir pour défendre son
intégrité territoriale
le fait que l'otan ni à la russie le
droit d'avoir un intérêt stratégique
il ne ferme influence ne veut pas dire
que l'homme je n'ai pas de stratégie et
de sphère d'influencé
ça veut dire simplement eu
ça qu'est la force sergueï lavrov pardon
a promis une proposition à venir on l'a
entendu déclaré que l'objectif était de
promouvoir une résolution pour éviter
l'extension de l'otan à quoi pourrait
ressembler cette résolution
honnêtement pour la santé me l'imaginé
très concrètement à quoi ça peut
ressembler puisqu'il existe déjà
beaucoup d'accords internationaux qui
visent à réguler les rapports politiques
entre les différents penny et chance
politique présente son continent
européen dans le vert
or comme l'a justement montre d'abord
élu au ce et mais aussi dans une map âge
puisque je suis maman la seule
résolution conjointe qui a pu être
adoptée c'est ce que marc alexandre ce
qui est fondamental de la sécurité
actuellement en europe quand on voit des
couples qui développe donc il faut faire
très attention à ces différents traités
qui peuvent donner une illusion de
sécurité est d'ailleurs à profit la a
rappelé plusieurs fois et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'à plusieurs
reprises les accords des six ans dating
qui sont revenus dans son discours avant
même que c'est rapport des films qui
avait plusieurs piliers notamment la
viabilité du joker en europe ce qui n'a
absolument rien empêché au niveau des
budgets les frontières lorsque cela a
été nécessaire pour faire tomber moment
soviétique et en france particulièrement
surtout ils ont celui qui s'était
engagée à incorporer le discours
occidental ce qui d'ailleurs a permis la
ronger de l'intérieur
donc le problème c'est que lorsque vous
aimez mettre en place à nouveau il faut
négocier
et qu'est ce que la russie de obtenir le
chef canton ne bougera pas
uniquement par un rapport des forces
politiques pas par un après crise et
juste lorsque cet actif il ne sera pas
nécessaire de toute façon il sera violée
donc c'est une question de chance hélas
choc 100 et ne passe pas que par le
texte le testing n'est pas appuyé par un
les arguments de troie qui n'ont rien à
voir rajoelina dans ce cas-là ce texte
n'a strictement aucun pouvoir pour
arrêter l'expansion de l'otan vers l'est
et par ailleurs l'autre danger tant de
savoir et qu'est ce que l'homme qui me
mettre dans ce cas là dans la
négociation puisque si guilbaut dossiers
sont qui se met en place elle demande à
ce que les bases de sid et internet
qu'est ce qu'elle va offrir vous faire
très attention à ce que finalement pas
beaucoup plus cher puisqu'il est gagnée
comme ce fut le cas
hayden et l'admirent poutine devrait
s'entretenir prochainement c'était une
demande notamment le de moscou qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre de ce prochain
sommet
ici d'imaginer vos puisse obtenir
quelque chose radicalement positif
puisque s'il y avait réellement une
volonté différente par aurait déjà pu
être fait par exemple ne l'a pas
nécessaire de finalement opter facto ces
diplomates font actuellement en fonction
c'est unique ou pas mauvais lavrov a
rappelé justement il serait possible
déjà de rentrer également la russie
c'est pour prier or lorsque l'on voit le
discours qui est tenu par le secrétaire
d'état américain qui parle toujours de
l'agression russe qui parle qui menace
la russie de sanctions et bly toujours
plus fort toujours plus loin on peut se
dire que ou parfois peut-être il serait
bon de ne pas rencontrer et ça aussi
c'est un film de force fait aussi un
moyen de montrer que le dialogue est
important dans ce qui permet d'obtenir
un résultat concret est intéressant pour
les deux parties mais ce n'est pas un
but en soi selon vous les états unis
selon vous les états unis washington ne
cherche pas
réellement de terrain d'entente avec
avec moscou non il ya les et unique h à
faire rentrer la russie dans la baie à
log dont eux maîtrisent les clés et donc
il maîtrise le les thèmes h or il n'est
pas forcément de l'intérêt de la russie
aujourd'hui d'entrer dans tous les
aspects il existe énormément de 10
patients de discussion il existe déjà
des des plateformes de discussion qui
permettent de développer les pendus des
uns et des autres notamment uniquement
russo américain les rencontres au sommet
ne doivent pas être banalisé il y en a
déjà eu il n'y a pas très longtemps pour
l'instant il faudrait peut-être déjà
amélioré des relations peut-être que
l'intérêt de la russie d'obtenir des
jeunes d'amélioration significative et
concrète et réelle
acheter cali dirigeant en fuite après
effectivement pourquoi pas continuer
mais pour l'instant vont pas très bien
en fait quel est l'intérêt stratégique
et pour résumer cette réunion de l'ouest
et es que le bilan qu'a dressé à sa
gueule avant ce n'est pas plutôt très
négatif je reprends ses termes tendance
négative qui se développe concernant la
sécurité et la coopération en europe une
approche discriminatoire quant à la
sécurité militaire elles se dégradent un
certain nombre d'accords ont cessé de
fonctionner l'intérêt finalement de
cette réunion à l'été où il est et où
je dirais que le vivant est produit par
faire gagner la gauche n'est pas négatif
les noirs mais malheureusement les
réalistes la sécurité en europe et dans
un état de délabrement avancé le fait
que les conflits perdurent le monde
l'engagement
compatible à je dirais avec
l'origine de sa création de l'ol c'est
que l'on voit notamment dans le donbass
et que organismes actuellement en
prenant de fonctionnement est inapte à
remplir différentes pour lequel il a été
créé c'est se demander d'ailleurs si en
fait le degré de conflictuelles entre
les états unis et la russie
cet organisme a finalement mieux que
challenge parce qu il ne peut pas y
avoir de consensus lorsqu'il n'ya une
différence réelle est fondamental de
vision du monde qu'il existe un combat
pour gagner sa vision du monde il c'est
le cas actuellement à l'époque avec
l'airé cesse et les etats unis appellent
seconde guerre mondiale il ya eu une
forme de coopération à certains moments
puisque chacun avec marquer son
territoire avec la chute de l'urss que
territoire est à redéfinir et
actuellement le problème est que le
temps attentes rapproche de plus en plus
de plus en plus en inde et fronty sein
de la ruche et les organes de sécurité
mis en place ne peuvent ne pas
fonctionner dans ce cas là puisque le
combattent en faut merci beaucoup pour
votre décryptage de cette prise de
parole de sergueï lavrov karine bêcher
golovkov je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou